[Music]
you guys say
yeah joystick t30 blah blah blah he's
not cheating he's [ __ ] cyborg they
defuse fight going down and choice TV
will see it and he will take down the
thermite joystick I mentioned before
Monsieur that highlight fragging play
made by soviet union's for they wanted
to build up a perfect soldier there's no
time left and joins ik again are you
what is going on and they food choice
thick the cyber play rainbows exceeds
and now he's the best joystick what
non-whites
joystick turns on uno absolute
destruction
Daniel Joystiq gabov isn't your
run-of-the-mill eSports competitor he's
Russia's resident siege superstar from
winning this outright and following a
pic like oh my god it goes it gets one
trip from behind his joy so where did
this humble hard-working phenom with
excellent aim and game sense come from I
suddenly started to play video games
because my father playing a lot in World
of Warcraft and some Starcraft and then
after it I with my sister started
playing computer games it was not
competitive if I just play for fun with
my friends
joysticks first exposure to eSports was
the very first international back in
2011 see the International the first one
for dota 2 and then I start to play but
I don't want to play strategies I tried
the tattoo but it's not for me so he
turned his attention back to a game that
he'd always been great at Counter Strike
I liked more shooters like I start from
websites or play the Lord with my
friends I could have like $6,000 there
once the 2010s rolled around joystick
had moved to moscow and was making a
name for himself as one of Russia's best
amateur csgo players I was top kind of a
player and face it but I can't find the
team i I think I really played good at
this game but we always change the
roster we always lose on the tournaments
and I want to swap the game and as fate
would have it joystick was about to
discover a different shooter one that
would change the course of his
competitive career I go to the
University right now I'm playing or I'm
studying at eSports University in Russia
and they they want to play us our csgo
roster - Rainbow six it was first
Russian tournament it was randomly yeah
yeah it's it's awesome how I start to
play siege and this game is awesome
desperate to make a name for himself
joystick spent 2017 serving short stints
on a variety of different stacks
before setting his sights on one of
Russia's best and up-and-coming orgs
room factory and the joystick was the
guy who has changed from csgo to the
Rainbow six siege he was spamming
shocking dears please like tryout me
tryout me tryout me and they just tried
them out and said he has all the
potentially I will just become up and
and the other keywords by January 5th
2018 rfy had made an impressive run
through the open ladder of the six
invitationals European qualifier a week
later they found themselves finishing
first overall in the most difficult
qualifier of the biggest siege
tournament in the world joystick up top
he's gonna use all of them here and
unfortunately the defuser is gonna get
dropped what is happening here rune
factory get three kills in a row and the
defenders of root factory will win the
round and make it 5 to 3 that just
completely fell at the end in spite of
their explosivity rfy were still a very
new team and come the main event in
February it became excruciating ly clear
that they still had a lot to learn we
was at the invitational 2018 we was like
one factory it was our first big
tournament and we we really played bed
there we'll need to try to evade the
blackbeard sight lines but one shot will
finish it off my freak will go back and
have one more chance at making the
Invitational a pack is here Mindfreak
eliminating eliminating room factory two
months after their windless elimination
from the invitational Joystiq Shepherd
and shockwave joined a bigger org Forza
due to an undisclosed conflict they left
after only two weeks but not before
befriended the newest member of their
core carjacker
when I first came into the team
I mentioned that joystick is if not one
of the best player right now that he
will be one of the best players in the
world under the name of identity
joystick and his teammates began their
tirade on Europe's semi-professional
scene before falling one series short of
qualifying for the six major in Paris
being said is taken back onto the site
and there we go they'll close it up Leon
gets with a final kill an ID K will know
the way in the way from the UK to Paris
it's coming home it's coming home
following Paris they took their first
step towards becoming a top-tier team
qualifying for Challenger League then we
improve a lot 21 here we need only one
year to improve like like these having
proven that they were the best team in
the CIS identity were quickly signed by
team Empire and it was under the Empire
banner that joystick and his core went
on to win season 3 of the European CCS
the ESL euro cup and on the back of
joysticks truly balls to the walls play
making a spot in pro league Joystiq
mentioned before must yeah the highlight
fragging yeah so if there's one player
to take a look at on team empire its
joystick and he will get deep-rooted the
very first frag of this series and now
it's a retake for the two roamers
joystick will not on White's joystick
turns on uno absolute destruction
joystick somehow has made himself
upstairs again how do you how do you how
do you get back upstairs joystick moon c
will take out Scyther and the phone call
you know how did you not hear it it
could be a free kill for joystick and it
will be after Wilkie takes down car Zeca
in the site though these kills from
joystick from above are going to be so
much more important the diffused plant
going down and joystick will see it and
he will take down the thermite boots the
eliminated and that puts it into a
two-on-two shocking the site will lose
to Wilkie but there's no time left and
joins Inc again are you what is going on
Empire win the round off the back of
joystick and joystick alone
empire have taken it congratulations
they make it into pro league and we'll
see them in just a few weeks for the
start of season nine by the end of 2018
Joystiq had solidified himself as sieges
newest nuttiest and most unexpected
superstar so like he has a set position
at set lane that he plays and like he'll
run into people that are prepared for
what he's doing and he's very good at
like just dealing with all the stuff
that people put and try to put in the
way of him and just like finding a way
around it finding a way to deal with it
he's very good at like just dealing with
the hand that he's dead I guess see that
was the thing about joystick
despite being touted as God's gift to
see he wasn't some divinely-inspired
Fragger with God to your aim in the
galaxy brain he just had this remarkable
ability to win to kill you at all costs
we and the one thing that sends out to
me is that people can often hold an
angle Crouch or standing up which means
you alter a head level and he always
Peaks dangle correctly like with our
crowd TP / cross level they're standing
if he starts like standing level cut
prone pro level and he's really really
really good at that he cleans out three
people in service and Bangalow and
that's only joints if I can do that in
fact it was around this time that
joystick started to develop a moniker of
sorts new guys say yeah joystick G
better blah blah blah he's not cheating
he's [ __ ] cyborg he only has like one
one objectives just just to kill you in
like if he sees you he's going for you
and he's gonna get you come December
Empire were entering Dreamhack winter
2018 has not only fan favorites but a
possible contender against the team who
held a monopoly on all of sieges
international competition the most
fearsome roster ever to touch the game
g2 eSports unfortunately it was g2 who
would stop a highly explosive Empire and
the freewheelin joystick dead and
tracks and that is the almost honest I'm
the shepherd if he pulls up since wasn't
versus work walk watcher will be but
there's too many players from g2 they
did such an easy victory over the
Russian champions the challenge early
champions but empire weren't deterred
they went on to dominate the sixth
Invitational 2019 s European qualifier
without dropping a single map and become
the main event they stomped their way
through both of the group stage and all
but the final series of the bracket
stage their Empire met the last
remaining obstacle between them and the
title of best in the world
g2 a blank against two will be a great
match for sure
in our opinion if you want to be the
best you need to beat the piss right the
tree is the best in the world so we want
that match and we want to win that this
one read it predicted like a month ago
Empire did you final I'm like there's no
way empire first you know there's a new
team that just made pro league and
somehow someway they've made all the way
to the final out with a pretty hot
bracket like they've been playing
extremely well I do finger better but I
expend you go like pretty close series
and in a sense it was close but after
edging out Empire in triple overtime on
map one and fending off an incredible
comeback on map to g2 caused the
Russians to collapse he needs to get
into the site and keep in mind in a for
b1
Beach as defending lane
fortunately Empire saw the end of their
cinderella story as a learning
experience a way to humble themselves
before undertaking their inaugural
season of pro league and meeting some of
the highest expectations a seed roster
had ever seen I think it's it's it's
really good that we are we are we play
second we are second place in this
tournament because sometimes when you're
winning everything your team haven't got
motivation you start to doing some crazy
things don't train a lot because you're
winning everything when we were little
mutations we were like on the three
months ago we were only in challenger
league so we didn't have like kind of a
lot of experience and when we faced it -
and after the crazy first map we were
just so exhausted and we were just
afraid of them so we were just afraid of
playing and thanks in part to joysticks
increasingly insane play empire were
able to meet those expectations logic
bombs give away positions that there is
joystick on in big double kill and
powerful force oasis you find yourself
in such a predicament at all which -
from joystick we understand each other
100% every one of us has their tasks in
the game and whenever like we say
joystick do something like here here and
whenever he does it we just saying like
ok now do whatever he want come the
season 9 Pro League finals in Milan a
tournament for which g2 didn't even
qualify Empire entered as clear
favorites there they toppled dark 0 and
fnatic to secure a spot in a grand
finals they were slated to dominate but
an overzealous Evil Geniuses had other
plans to come out at some please get the
UMP and n he'll play around these bars
will be able to land the shots no Gino
gets that how about a flawless round how
about a start as good as you're gonna
find from eg evil genius is really well
arrayed he can't all run out because he
won't have time to get back and that's
it
round four fitted neck rocks gets the
last kill and evil geniuses take map
number one in this best of three worst
of all it wasn't a flute Empire
proceeded to take an unthinkable deficit
in map two and it was right then as soon
as eg found themselves on a championship
point that's something crazy happened
down on white stairs waiting for the
vault on in is Canadian will he be able
to secure the kill he sees the tracers
don't know
Scyther will win the fight he'll inch
his way on up Gio is gonna be next in
line but this could be a tough shot an
empire could wrestle away the round
there's Gio just waiting he doesn't pull
the trigger he sees he pops up oh no Gio
you gotta hit your shots young will be
the last one left he was so important
for faze he turns his back he's got the
pistol but shepard will deny the come
back from ichi on that round and the
hopes and dreams will wave one more
round at minimum thanks to empires
remarkable resilience Ichi were simply
unable to close pressure from behind she
or might not be aware that there's a
Nevada there
we got Empire going to overtime with eg
three rounds unanswered and eg will
choke the lead they had and they'll need
to think about that in OT we have really
big motivation to win this tournament
because there is no g2 there is only eg
we prepare for them a lot and we we need
with this win for for us for our
community for yeah that's why we have a
lot of motivation for winning this by
the time they hit their signature map
Clubhouse Empire had taken hold of the
series and despite a G's last-ditch
effort at showing signs of life Empire
had positioned themselves to make one of
the most stunning comeback since each
history the information only takes one
we'll rise as you crown a new champion
here in the lawn
an edition of Dan to this team proves to
be what's needed and this miracle
comeback from Evil Geniuses
will be all but a dream Empire are your
season nine champions finally after a
year of anticipation Joystiq had grinded
his way to the top the question was
whether he'd be able to stay there once
g2 were back in the mix Joystiq spent
the next three months gearing up for the
next international Ubisoft hosted
tournaments the six major in Raleigh
given the state of Zhi Zhu's Pro League
record and the fact that they hadn't
played al and in six months
the community was unsure whether g2
still had what it took to put an end to
empires undeniable explosivity as for
Empire well they were hell-bent on
beating g2 I think it's the most
important thing for us in all
tournaments if he if we seem to do we
need we know that we need to beaten them
in Final with both teams topping their
respective groups the community awaited
an empire g2 final with bated breath and
while both teams did in fact make it to
the end of the bracket stage g2 did so
without dropping a single map empire on
the other hand as astral finishes off
site there and now they've done it
joining the elite company of one other
team face clan will take empires map and
we're gonna go all the way to consulate
from that three in a really defiant
performance a 71 victory Sheppard is
off-site grab the diffuser and plant but
above the man who has always last alive
has the marks he knows they're there but
he can't out duel the beam he gets in at
the last second that's the
Russians go into the semi-finals Volkers
fine Stan it's all left up to Shephard
inside of sight and we're going to map
three folks Dave secret finds empires
map to just drop there's the only one
instead of small office
nobody home currently a pre-fire comes
out but he's not going to meet Dan
Shepard still playing inside of work
office as well excuse me workshop let's
rotate at the bottom of the metal that's
a quick shot in its Shepard
that's Empire go to the best-of-five on
Sunday and make it once again to yet
another grand final team Empire the
Russian machines they are unstoppable
as they push onward into a grand final
once again finally after days of
grueling anguish Empire had made it to
their third consecutive grand finals a
first for any team who weren't there
faded opponents g2 Empire can win a
tournament but not at least going
through us first but I'm okay with
keeping the Milan and get the rematch
here in a best-of-five grand final
infinte overtime like last time I want
to go more than three is here this time
I can go three one three two maybe let's
make it not so fast and fortunately for
Penghu he got his wish
no it does not appear so and they have
to swing out but joystick as the cover
he fights to for his trouble and it's a
successful plan Empire everything in
their favor and it's all on Penghu he
was great the round before he'll find
cars a cup at this three more members of
empire to deal with takes out the drone
falls off penguin will swing on a
joystick but for the first time ever the
Russians will take a map against g2 and
they're up one nothing but g2 wouldn't
go down without a fight
we're on in sight they're looking to try
and start it while he'll get one he also
catches Koga but the Spaniard with one
HP downs and and removes him from the
equation Shepard nestled up in the
bombsite throws out a toxic canister
but there's no clutch here all the magic
runs out and you can see as gogo wipes
his brows
it's a heroic coming back from g2 and
they'll take map number two and neither
would Empire now a Shepherd pops up he
sees water oiled absolutely crush Udo
Shepherd oh my god
thank you now @ o1 v3 is position giving
away an empire looking to sit pretty
amidst the smoke as Penghu then Empire
will do something they had it done until
today which is take a map off of g2
they've taken two of them now and
they're gonna be on Ceres point it was
only fitting that the fight moved on to
coast line
this was G choose map a fact that
joystick was reminded of rather quickly
they also know that they need to get on
the top floor before they can hit
sufficient answer Kenny on the top floor
by billiards it will take on joystick
it's coming for the main lobby but he's
gonna find three in just five seconds
he gets one with a knight but can he
find a second the answer nearly yes but
ultimately no G to take the round with
beautiful positioning and then just as
it was starting to look as if g2 were
running away with it
joystick turn the Jets on like givin in
the Grand Finals we were just ok we are
not afraid of them joystick if you feel
something or everyone at you someone
feels that he needs to do something just
do it no questions joystick sprints in
and he'll win the fight
perfectly tracking Kanto riccati he's
trying to retake from us aqua but he's
known these angles played by joystick
are perfect there you go Empire take the
round you got a ping outside you're
gonna go for the hole but it's not
advised joystick was waiting for it he
read you like a book
these teams will draw even joysticks
been having a really good Matt
overall 38 to 30 is really really
impressive riding on the back of
joysticks tenacity empire were able to
rack up win an empire first time in this
map we'll take a lead after wind we're
staring at an indeed a flawless round
after win empire push us on to match
point
until finally they'd put up six rounds
in a row and were moments away from
putting the so-called g2 dynasty to a
sudden and in fat again joysticks still
not aware Brad but it is to kill story
for Shepard and the Empire Strikes Back
they will take the rolling major and
disbelief how quickly it comes yeah I
mean it means a lot like it's one thing
to win like g2 in online might in the
best of one but the other it's like
completely another thing to win them on
land in the best-of-five serious and you
know on a free one score that's
something indescribable ultimately it
isn't actually that clear what it is
that makes joysticks such a special
player that's the thing we have that
discussion on team almost every event
but like he doesn't look amazing on
paper he doesn't have like you know
shroud aim he doesn't have any of that
but he's like the most performing player
of recent times basically that he's the
new Ken so if anything with a new nest
as people call it and while he may not
be an aimbot in the traditional sense
there's no denying his incredible talent
he kind of sprung up out of nowhere you
know going from Challenger League to Pro
League until just basically like a good
grand final like all the time just again
raw raw skill the dude's a maniac he
just has this indescribable ability to
outplay his opponents to do exactly the
right thing at the right time I guess
joysticks just test
he just has that feeling in his himself
like in the body or in this spirit I
don't know how to say that he just knows
when and what he needs to do
he's helped usher in an entirely new era
of siege and as far as we can tell he
has no intention of letting up I want to
be remember like first-team coup could
be due to three or two or three times in
a row internally thanks for watching if
you want more content like this hit the
sub button and ring that notification
bell for unique bite-sized videos you
will find anywhere else hit up our
Instagram Twitter and Facebook pages
[Music]